Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
They released a couple of new Spider-Man
Beyond the Spider-Verse teasers
so we'll break it all down.
There's a couple of big Easter eggs
that give us some more information
about what's going on between Miles
Morales, Spider-Man in Miles
Morales, as they're calling him
on this alternate earth.
there was also news
about the actual release date
being pushed, things being delayed, things
going on behind the scenes.
All explained what's going on with that.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
The first big thing is this new scene.
It seems like a work in progress
or it might get worked
into beyond the spider-verse
in some way
in the next couple of years were Aaron
Davis is still the prowler
you could see him in his suit here
teaching a slightly younger looking miles
G Morales is they're calling him
that's what they're calling this
prowler version of miles from earth 42.
and it looks like they're stealing
medical supplies
from the Sinister Six cartel and
giving them to his mother at her hospital
just because she doesn't have enough
to treat her patients.
So she's very thankful
but doesn't completely realize
what's actually going on.
Like, oh, some vigilante left me supplies.
there was also some tie in material
in some of the art books
that they released that teased.
What's going on with this Miles G.
Morales alternate reality prowler version
of the character to confirming that
he's kind of a Robin Hood
type of character
vigilantes stealing to help his mother,
stealing from the rich, a.k.a.
the Sinister
Six cartel, giving to the poor.
and if you look at a lot of his
moves, too, they're very Spider-Man
like in the way that he's web
slinging around kind of using Prowler
tech, almost doing the exact same thing.
He looks very similar or his moves look
very similar to the regular Miles Morales.
Spider-Man's
he just doesn't have any actual webbing
so he's using practical technology
and it seems like his mother
in this reality and earth 42 doesn't know
that he's becoming the prowler
or has become the prowler
she probably only knows
that there's a vigilante out there
that calls themself
the prowler that's in the news.
Who helps her,
gives people things that they need.
But just like regular Miles
Morales mother, she also hasn't
totally figured out that this Miles
Morales her Miles Morales
hasn't become the prowler on their world.
so a lot of people were wondering
what's going to happen
after the end of Spider-Man
across the Spider-Verse
because they tease this big fight
between the two of them, like he's slowly
escaping using his shocker ability
it's meant to be a big callback
to Spider-Man into the spider-verse,
where Peter
Parker used his abilities to escape
while Miles was talking to him.
so Miles is going to start Spider-Man
be on the Spider-Verse
doing the same thing,
escaping from this situation
and even though the way
they play the music, like the big reveal,
they want you to think like Miles
Morales is a villain.
The idea is that
they're trying to tell you through
all these tie ins in these teasers
that really he's a vigilante.
He's not an outright villain.
That was what the regular Miles
Morales Spider-Man was talking to Earth
42 Aaron Davis about before he realized
what was really going on.
he was trying to tell him
about his Uncle Aaron before he died.
He wanted to be good,
but he didn't know how.
so they want to let you know that
that's kind of going on with this Miles G.
Morales Prowler version of the character.
a lot of people were wondering
if they're actually going to fight
or if they're going to take a hard left
turn and just surprise everyone
and he won't be a villain.
Like he'll actually help this version
of Spider-Man.
Miles Morales my early theory
and some of my previous videos
is that he would eventually do that,
but there'd be like a small fight,
Like you have to have them fight
just a little bit.
But the end game idea is the prowler.
Miles Morales.
Miles Morales is not going to wind up
being a villain.
my other early theory is that he would
eventually wind up fighting the Sinister
Six cartel on his earth,
and they would set
those group of characters
up as bigger villains on Earth.
42 they won't walk back Miles Morales
Spider bite or anything like that.
Like he'll go back to his ultimate
universe Earth. but.
At the end of the day, Miles
Morales will just continue
becoming a better version of the Prowler
and become more of a good character,
so to speak, more of a traditional,
good character
trying to defeat the Sinister Six cartel
there will be a group super powerful
on this earth, it's
not something
that he would completely wrap up
during beyond the spider-verse
like he would just continue
fighting the Sinister
Six cartel on his earth into adulthood.
so part of the idea
is that even in an alternate reality,
even though things went completely
terrible for him, like his father died,
he didn't become Spider-Man,
the traditional type of hero.
Things still worked out
like he's still good in this reality.
Fundamentally,
there was a longer character
description for this prowler,
Miles Morales two that they released.
So it says Miles Morales, a.k.a.
The Prowler, is the alternate reality
version of Miles,
who grew up completely different from him.
this version of the character
was never bitten by a radioactive spider
and doesn't have any superpowers.
But he has fallen into the role
of becoming a vigilante.
The Prowler notices this A vigilante,
not villain.
under the tutelage of his uncle,
Aaron, Miles comes face to face
with his other version of himself
and realizes
that because one thing
dropped the other way,
everything has changed due to the
butterfly effect, where one small change
can later result in larger changes
to a deterministic, non-linear system.
in this case an entire reality, says
director Justin Kate Thompson Internally,
we decided to call this parallel world
version Miles G.
Morales To avoid confusion.
So we think that just confirms
that we'll see like a very brief miles
versus miles G.
MORALES At the beginning of Spider-Man,
beyond the Spider-Verse
until they both realize what's going on.
Oh, we're not bad people.
We want to help each other.
while this is happening,
Gwen assembles her own team
paying off her line
from earlier at the movie
at the beginning about
never finding the right band to be in
the team is meant to be the right band.
Here is everyone from the first movie,
in addition
to spider Punk who's come back
Spider-Man India in Spider bite.
Who all in the movie entering the portal
to earth 42 to rescue Miles.
So beyond the Spider-Verse
is meant to pick up immediately
after these moments, like literally right
as he's escaping the punching bag
Spider Gwen's team will be way
more focused on stopping the spot
and saving Miles's father.
You can let me know if you think the spot
will wind up killing one of his parents,
or they'll make it in time
to save both of them.
They really want you to wonder
if one of them is going to survive.
But here's the thing about the spot.
I think the reason why they kept hyping up
the evolution of miles is spider
Stinger shock ability is to show
that he can drain the spots
dark matter energy,
just like he drains other types of energy.
It'll just mess miles up big time,
absorbing all that dark matter
early theory.
He also starts
bleeding a little from his armpits
just because it messes him up so bad,
paying off the jokes
about his new suit in the movie
a couple of different characters
repeat that joke about him
bleeding from the armpits in the movie, in
like Peter B Parker says they'll
build him a new suit
at the end of the movie.
There was a montage earlier in the movie
about building new suits.
They're all based on comic book suits.
There was even a cape based suit
that he designed,
which is a reference
to the Spider-Man Cape jokes.
Earlier in the first movie.
And it's a no on the Cape.
I think it's cool.
Take that off. It's disrespectful.
that Miles leaves his mother like
this is the last time that he sees her
in this movie saying that he promised
that he would come back and he promised
that he would have a nice cake.
That's not all messed up So early
prediction is that's how they end.
Beyond the spider-verse,
they stopped the spot from collapsing.
All of reality.
Spider-Man 2099 comes around on him
and finally leaves him alone
and they have some shawarma tags
seen at the end of the movie
where he comes
home to his parents with a nice cake and
introduces them to the rest of his friends
that he mentioned at the beginning
of across the Spider-Verse
and they all eat cake that he brings back
with him, including Spider Ham.
like he was about to tell his mother
a couple of times.
Then he tells the wrong earth
40 to mother.
He'll probably tell his parents
that he is Spider-Man
at the end of the movie to the other thing
about the spot in Beyond the Spider-Verse
is that he's doing all this
collapsing reality
because he thinks that Miles
was responsible for everything
or at least blames him
for everything that happened.
And he thinks that Miles doesn't take him
seriously.
Miles.
Sounds like he's going to try and talk him
down a little bit in addition
to powering him with his stinger ability.
But instead of locking him up
for the rest of all time like a normal
supervillain,
early theory is that Miles wins him over.
So he kills out and eventually tries
to help him and just use his power,
his brains for good in the future.
during the comics,
the spot was both a villain and a hero.
So I think they're just playing on that
same idea. Like he could go either way.
They'll end things
in a more hopeful way in the spot.
We'll actually start doing some good
just address all the stuff
that's happening
behind the scenes.
There's been a lot of news
about the actual movie itself,
the making of the movie.
Originally
it was supposed to come out in early 2024.
But a lot of people that are working on
the movie, even Hailee Steinfeld, said
that she hasn't recorded any dialog for it
yet in when she was recording dialog
for Across the Spider-Verse.
That happened years
before the movie came out.
so the whole idea is that if she hasn't
even started recording voiceover dialog,
there are way, way for like it's going
to take way longer for them to complete.
And then a lot of people
behind the scenes,
a lot of animators were complaining
about the working conditions.
so the producers, Phil Lord, Chris
Miller said that they have no actual set
release date.
They would just continue making the movie
until it was like they'll take
as long as they need,
which is code for it's
going to take way longer
to make the movie.
so right now everybody assumes
that it's going to be 2025
before the movie comes out.
It could be a little bit longer.
But I think just to be a little more
optimistic,
we'll say it'll take an extra year
for them to finish it
because they have already started
working on it.
ages that they're not nearly as far along
in the process
as people would have assumed.
In related news, also puts that movie
closer to the release date of Spider-Man
four with Tom Holland.
Live action in the MCU.
now that also might wind up
getting delayed because of all the strikes
that are happening right
now. There's a writer's strike.
There's an actor strike
that might wind up happening.
A lot of the big studios
like Sony, Marvel, even DC,
canceled their Comic-Con plans.
So there's no big Hall
H panel happening for anybody.
but there's still a bunch of stuff
that's coming out.
The stuff that's getting delayed is stuff
that's like a couple of years out.
For example, Spider-Man for I've
already done a bunch of videos about this.
But the big thing that's happening,
big connection between Spider-Man
beyond the Spider-Verse in Spider-Man four
and in the Tom Holland live action
Spider-Man movies
is that they're now developing live action
Miles Morales movies, too.
They didn't say
exactly how that's going to go down,
but there was rumors
he was going to appear in some way
in Spider-Man four a little while ago,
when across the Spider-Verse hit theaters,
Shameik Moore was talking about this deal
like he really wanted to play the live
action.
Miles Morales And one of my early theories
a couple of years ago
was that they would eventually just move
some of these animated characters
in the live action
because they're blending
so many live action
elements into across the Spider-Verse
in beyond the Spider-Verse
they even said that
there were some deleted scenes
where they did more live action
crossover with the animation,
like they had the venom cameos scene
where he goes to Venom's Earth
in the movie.
They were bigger scenes like that
where you see
live action elements in animated elements
together.
the reason why they went up
cutting a lot of that stuff
out of the movie is because they said
it just looked too ridiculous.
If that's even possible.
So. If we do see some of these
animated spider-verse characters
show up in Avengers Secret Wars,
I think that they'll try to tune
that just a little bit
just to make it a little bit better.
for example, it'd be really cool
to see them substitute the spider force
like Spider-Man 2099, giant team
of Spider-Man from across the multiverse
for the Thor Corps
in the traditional secret war story.
we'll probably start
getting some more beyond
the Spider-Verse teasers later this year.
So of course I'll do more videos as we see
more Easter eggs or deleted scenes,
so leave all your requests in the comments
below.
Everyone click Here for My Secret Invasion
Episode three Video
and click here for that new Fantastic
Four Doctor
Doom Secret Invasion Trailer.
Video two Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!